[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine ganz tolle advents
torte wir werden nämlich eine preise
torte mit einer show kooistra susanne
machen keine angst war kein ist presse
mag für den habe ich auch eine
alternative und die torte ist wirklich
in der herstellung supereinfach ihnen
habe ich eine richtig große frucht
einlage das heißt fruchtig ist sie auch
und außen habe ich sie gemeinsam mit
solaera dekoriert ich werde jetzt zuerst
einmal den bizkit herstellen dass es so
ein stracciatella biscuit und dafür
zeige ich euch hier vorne mal die
zutaten für den biskuit brauch ich sechs
eiweiß eine prise salz 90 gramm zucker
sechs eigelb 45 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt 130 gramm mehl und wer
möchte fügt noch 150 gramm
schokostreusel hinzu beim bizkit können
wir gerne die eier auch zusammen lassen
und dann die eier zucker mischung etwa
20 bis 25 minuten lang rühren oder macht
so wie ich mit der getrennten variante
ich zeige euch antwort immer gerne weit
ist also jetzt habe ich hier weist und
es kommt jetzt in eine saubere und
fettfreie schüsse so hat man einfach den
vorteil dass noch ein bisschen mehr
volumen dazu kommt wobei ich finde wenn
man es wirklich ganz ganz lange rührt
diese eier zucker mischung dann macht es
fast keinen unterschied da kommen jetzt
noch salz mit dazu jetzt kann ich den
einschnitten steif schlagen und dann die
90 gramm zucker zufügen und langsam
einrühren
[Musik]
jetzt ist der wunderbar
und jetzt kann ich die schüssel wechseln
und in dieser zweiten schüssel das
eigelb gemeinsam mit dem restlichen
zucker und dem vanille extrakt verrühren
und das ganze dann für etwa zehn minuten
damit die eier masse richtig schön weiß
cremig wird
[Musik]
jetzt ist die eier maße schön cremig und
auch stabil
und jetzt werde ich den rest aber mit
dem teig schau ma bzw mit einem
schneebesen per unterheben
das heißt das mehl kommen jetzt dazu und
wird gesiebt und dann kommen noch die
streusel mit rein
am anfang geht mich jemand gern noch ein
bisschen schnee dazu dann kann man das
ganze besser verrühren
und jetzt ganz vorsichtig den restlichen
einschnitt unterheben
[Musik]
ich mag jetzt die bi suite würden alle
gleichzeitig falls aber nur einen
backofen habt was eben normal ist dann
macht am besten erst die hälfte des
tages back 2 bilden und dann könnt ihr
den restlichen tag auch noch mal packen
damit er bis wird einfach nicht so lange
rum steht ohne gebacken zu werden
jetzt kann ich nämlich den teig
aufteilen auf 4 back trainiert die habe
ich bereits auf 20 cm durchmesser
eingestellt ihr könnt aber auch
alternativ nur zwei backen verwenden und
einfach einen höheren teig backen und
diesen später beschneiden
[Musik]
für die frucht einlage brauche ich 500
gramm preiselbeeren aus dem glas 30
gramm zucker den saft einer mandarine
oder auch zitrone 200 milliliter
orangensaft ein päckchen acker das sind
15 gramm und eine zimtstange ich presse
zuerst einmal den orangensaft aus da
können die entweder frische orangen
nehmen oder auch orangensaft aus der
flasche und ihr könnt auch stadt der
preiselbeer gerne auch andere früchte
neben himbeeren oder kirschen zum
beispiel das schmeckt genauso gut ein
bisschen anders
[Musik]
der orangensaft kommt jetzt hier in
einen topf freien presse jetzt auch den
mandarinen oder zitronensaft dazu
das gibt noch mal einen richtig tollen
geschmack mit rein jetzt kommt hier die
zimtstange mit rein und auch das aka aka
und wird jetzt schön verrührt und dann
las ich den orangensaft gemeinsam mit
dem agatha und der film stange aufkochen
und dann mindestens zwei minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen
jetzt nehme ich die zimtstange heraus
die könnte jetzt zum beispiel
weiterverwenden und könnten bei machen
oder auch einen kinderpunsch und da die
zimtstange einfach nur mit aufkochen
jetzt fröhlich ein bisschen auf dem
löffel geht es schlecht aber jetzt ruhig
ein bisschen was von dem preiselbeeren
in die heiße masse ein
die preise band sind ja kalt und daher
würde ich das sofort geliert wenn ich
das hier sofort mit rein gebe daher
könig setzt hier ein bisschen ab so und
jetzt kann ich das komplette agar agar
hiermit zu den preisen bern geben
jetzt könnt ihr das hier mal abschmecken
und wenn es euch schon süß genug ist
braucht ihr keinen zucker wenn es euch
nicht süß genug ist könnt ihr gerne ein
bisschen zucker eingeben aber ich finde
es immer ganz wichtig dass die frucht
anlagen nicht so süß sind und
normalerweise bei himbeeren zum beispiel
gibt es gar keinen zucker mit rein weil
ich möchte dass die frucht einlage
säuerlicher schmeckt und die creme dafür
ein bisschen saison jetzt gebe ich hier
einen teelöffel von dieser masse auf
einem kleinen teller und stellt den
kühlschrank und dann kann ich schon
innerhalb von zwei bis drei minuten
feststellen ob die masse verliert und so
lange kann das hier ein bisschen
abkühlen bevor ich dann in den
tortenring ein fülle hier bei der jury
prof seht ihr dass die masse und fest
geworden ist im kühlschrank und es ist
wirklich immer ein ganz ganz toller tipp
vor allem könnte man sicher gehen dass
die creme und auch die frucht einer
super gelingt jetzt kann ich die frucht
einlage in einem torten bringt einfüllen
ich habe zu einem mit zwölf zentimetern
durchmesser
ihr könnt natürlich auch einfach eine
schüssel nehmen die dazu passt ihr könnt
aber auch mehrere frucht einlagen machen
aber ich finde jetzt ganz schön eine
große zu haben
und da habe ich jetzt eine
frischhaltefolie drunter und gibt es
hier alles rein jetzt noch ein bisschen
schütteln wenn man es schön glatt wird
und die frischhaltefolie habe ich
darunter damit ich die frucht einlage
später natürlich auch vom torten retter
wieder runter bekommen die wir jetzt
eingefroren für etwa eine stunde dann
sollte sie schon fest sein und dann
können wir nämlich schon unsere leckere
rückraum machen
die frucht einlage ist jetzt fest die
bis mit böden sind abgekühlt das heißt
ich kann mich jetzt um die schokocreme
kümmern für die schokocreme brauche ich
100 gramm herren schokolade oder
zartbitterschokolade zwei heiße espresso
250 gramm mascarpone 7 teelöffel seiner
partei 500 gramm magerquark 400
milliliter sahne und nochmal vier
teelöffel sommerparty zuerst nämlich
jetzt die herren schokolade die habe ich
bereits fein gehackt und da kommen jetzt
die 2000 espresso dazu richtig heiß
damit die schokolade auch schmilzt und
das ganze für rühre ich jetzt einfach
ganz kurz business klümpchen frei ist
[Musik]
übrigens kein espresso in der torte
haben mag kann auch zum beispiel ein
bisschen sahne nehmen aufkochen und
darin die schokolade lösen oder auch zum
verfeinern ein bisschen likör oder auch
um nehmen jetzt gebe ich die schokolade
in der größere schüssel damit ich das
ganze verrühren kann und wichtig ist
jetzt dass die schoko maße nicht mehr zu
heiß ist also ihr können zu ruhig ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen
ich rühre sie jetzt einfach ein bisschen
kalt und gibt dann die mascarpone und
den quark leichter so
[Musik]
die gebe ich jetzt noch die sieben
teelöffel salat mit rein und verrührt
das ganze ganz kurz wichtig ist dass sie
jetzt nicht zu lange rheurdt da dem
oscar ansonsten gewinnen kann so wie bei
sahne eben auch und in der zwischenzeit
werde ich die sahne nehmen mit dem
restlichen sonderfahrt und schreibt
schlagen
[Musik]
was du dich denn puderzucker vergessen
so ist die creme schon noch ziemlich
hart aber ich gebe jetzt noch 50 gramm
puderzucker zur sahne dazu und dann
mitte perfekt
und jetzt kann ich noch die sahne
unterheben
jetzt ist es an der zeit die torte zu
füllen ich habe jetzt hier schon mal den
ersten tortenboden auf einen top berater
darauf gegeben und da streiche ich jetzt
ein bisschen 100 orten creme drauf so
soll nur als kleber dienen für die
frucht einlage
die lösung ist einmal vom tortenring
und diese schön fest aber nicht ganz
gefroren aber bei der größe ist das
völlig okay kann ich jetzt hier mit sich
platzieren und jetzt diesen tortenring
nehmen und die übrigen böden ausstechen
und zwar einmal hier in der mitte
der mittlere part kommt weg jetzt setze
ich hier einen tortenring außenrum damit
die creme auch schon fest wird und jetzt
finde ich hier einen zentimeter hoch die
creme rein und das geht am besten jetzt
mit einem spritzbeutel da könnt ihr
nämlich die creme einfüllen und dann
schon rein spritzen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier wieder die creme darauf
der nächste boden wird auch ausgestochen
und draufgelegt und der letzte kommt
aber als abschluss ganz oben drauf
[Musik]
auf diese schicht kommt jetzt 1 1 cent
oder creme schicht und dann schließlich
mit dem deckel auf mit einem torten
raptor kann ich die torte jetzt abdecken
und für mindestens 4 stunden kühl
stellen
die restliche creme kommt auch in den
kühlschrank und in der zwischenzeit
zeige ich euch wie man richtig tolle
schoko deko machen kann
ergebnis als hände waschen und dann die
torte die torte ist jetzt gerade noch im
kühlschrank und jetzt kann ich die
schokoladen deko herstellen dafür habe
ich 200 gramm peter kuvertüre bereits
fein gehackt und jetzt ist ganz wichtig
dass die kuvertüre temperiert wird das
heißt sie muss auf die richtige
temperatur kommen damit sie keinen
grauschleier kommt und das bekommt ihr
am besten mit der methode hin
das heißt ich koche zu ein bisschen
wasser auf und nimmt dann das wasser
wieder vom herd herunter und höre jetzt
zwei drittel deck ouvertüre in einer
schüssel über dem warmen wasserbad so
lange bis die kuvertüre geschmolzen ist
und jetzt hat die kuvertüre etwa 50 grad
und mit dem restlichen drittel der
kuvertüre dass ich noch übrig habe kann
ich die kuvertüre herunterkühlen dass
sich neben sie zum wasserbad herunter
und chöre so lange bis die stückchen weg
sind und so sieht sie jetzt aus hat die
perfekte temperatur und glänzt richtig
schön
jetzt habe ich hier eine bank folie ihr
könnt auch bei papier nehmen
da kommt jetzt die kurve tore drauf das
ist eine super einfache deko also
wirklich toll einfach alles drauf geben
jetzt kenne ich es hier schon mal ein
bisschen verstreichen
und jetzt kommt eine zweite folie drauf
die wird jetzt drauf geklebt ganz
vorsichtig verstreichen und jetzt am
besten mit einem ausfall starb drüber
rollen nur aufpassen dass es unten nicht
raus gewählt
wenn doch ist auch nicht schlimm
passiert
und jetzt hat die schoko platte ungefähr
die größe von meiner dauer back folie
jetzt nehme ich den aus holz starb und
rolle den 1
und dadurch wird die schoko platte jetzt
praktisch rund gerollt wie so eine ja
wieso eine zentrale und so werde ich sie
fest werden lassen im kühlschrank und
später wenn ich sie dann auf rolle wird
ein richtig toller effekt also jetzt
kurz im kühlschrank herd kühlschrank
in der zwischenzeit kann ich ja schon
mal die torte vom torten rand lösen
jetzt sehe ich sie aber zuerst auf eine
tortenplatte das geht immer am besten
wenn der bug ring noch außen rum ist
so kann sie sich nicht verformen und
jetzt hier vorne öffnen und dann mit dem
backform messer lösen
[Musik]
die restliche creme nämlich jetzt um die
torte komplett einzustreichen
[Musik]
die tat ist jetzt fertig gestrichen und
ich hatte es ja auch noch mal ganz kurz
in der kühlung
die platte ist jetzt auch fest und jetzt
breche ich sehr auseinander ich glaube
mein herz ganz gut
und im prinzip ist es immer eine
überraschung wie die schokolade dann
aussieht
[Musik]
so sieht die turtles grad aus samira hat
mit mir gemeinsam die schoko später noch
angeklebt und jetzt nehmen wir ein
bisschen strecke also in gold sterne und
kugeln setzen die hier noch oben drauf
und dann noch ein bisschen preise
wärmste nur hier an den rand okay nicht
in die mitte ist die mitte lassen war
frei
super oder ich glaube dann machen wir
jetzt gar keine preise bei mir um drauf
wenn die preise bei uns stecken ja
drinnen
das heißt wir können die torte
anschneiden
bin ich auf der anschnitt gespannt das
messer mache ich übrigens beim schneiden
immer gerne sauber dann sieht es trotz
stück immer super aus
[Musik]
das lustig beim schneiden da stört man
sogar die frucht
boah indes nicht mal ein schöner abend
schnitt ist murat ist leider leider
nicht da mal wieder
ich weiß in letzter zeit damit arbeiten
was soll er tun muss was tun für sein
weihnachtsgeld
also muss ich jetzt probieren ich bin
mal gespannt denn ich hab selber auch
noch nie preise bei einer torte gegessen
bisher kenne ich das eigentlich nur von
herzhaften rezepten also vom wild zum
beispiel wobei ich darüber muss ich echt
gestehen nicht so gerne mag aber in der
torte fand ich jetzt ziemlich
interessant also probieren die torte die
stadt hama müsst ihr auf jeden fall
probieren
man schmeckt auf jeden fall den espresso
raus aber nicht dominant nicht so stark
der unterstützt vor allem den presse
beigeschmack richtig gut und die herren
schokolade passt auch perfekt dazu falls
sie also das rezept nach machen wollt
ich empfehle euch sehr
dann schaut auf meinem blog vorbei aufs
eis - blog.de da steht es noch mal ganz
genau die torte auf jeden fall nicht zu
süß trifft genau meinen geschmack und
ich bin froh dass ich die preise beim
benutzt habt also viel spaß beim
nachmachen wir sehen uns das nächste
immer wieder biss dann hmm mist
probieren nur mein gott
einmal team meinung im mist einfach
probieren frucht creme boden
tomtom ich helfe dir aus beide hände
kraft gut oder es kommt mir preise
werden nicht vorstellen in der torte
aber dann doch und jetzt probiere mega
mega gut gehe und sie sieht so schön aus
also machte nach bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss bord morabit begeistert sein
jetzt schneidet man fährt raus dann
sehen wir noch mal richtig gut rein
[Musik]